[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, I'm Reto Meier
for "The Developer Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
A new set of
experimental features
are now available to
use on the Lenovo Mirage
Solo, our standalone
Daydream headset.
These include the
experimental six degrees
of freedom controllers,
see-through mode,
and smartphone
Android apps in VR.
Take a look at the post
linked in the description
below for screen caps
and links to get started.
Flutter Release Preview 2,
our last major milestone
before Flutter 1.0,
is now available.
The theme for this release
is pixel-perfect iOS apps.
Also included in
this is the ability
to execute Dart code
in a background,
even while the
application is suspended,
and a reduction of up to 30%
in application package size.
More details and links to
get started are in the post.
Google Data Studio is our free
modern business intelligence
product.
Cloud Dataprep is our fully
managed data preparation
product, powered by Trifacta.
Both are now
generally available.
To learn more about how to
use them to organize, access,
and understand your
world of information,
head on over to the post.
We recently announced
the Cloud Inference API.
It's a simple, highly
efficient, and scalable system
that makes it easier for you
to quickly gather insights
from type to time
series data sets.
It's also fully integrated
with Google Cloud Storage
and can handle data sets as
large as tens of billions
of event records.
More details and a link
to join the public alpha
are on the post.
Advanced Machine
Learning with TensorFlow
on Google Cloud
Platform's specialization
is now available on Coursera.
It will help you gain
skills in building
more sophisticated
and state of the art
models to solve
enterprise problems.
It consists of
five courses, which
are all detailed on the post.
Cloud Memorystore for Redis
is now generally available.
It is a fully managed,
in-memory datastore service,
built on Google's highly
scalable and reliable
infrastructure, that
automates complex tasks
such as provisioning, scaling,
failover, and monitoring,
so you can focus on
your application, not
your IT operations.
You can get started
with the post.
Code Search is now
available in beta
in the newly
revamped Cloud Source
Repositories with
an entirely new user
interface and semantic
Code Search capabilities.
For more details and to get
started with the new Cloud
Source Repositories,
head on over to the post
linked in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Reto Meier for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Includes the experimental six
degrees of freedom controllers.
[STAMMERING]
SPEAKER: So close.
RETO MEIER: So close.
So close to saying a consonant.